[Musique]
environnement toujours pour continuer ce
78 avec l'association vilverte bonsoir à
nos deux nouvelles invitéses Cindy
godudin donc chargé de mission et
animatrices pour l'association et Roxane
og animatrice environnement le mercredi
c'est club nature une fois par mois 12
jeunes de plus de 8 ans qui viennent à
la Maison de l'Environnement à Manil
etamo pour des animations le prochain
rendez-vous c'est dès demain le 12
décembre que fait-on dans ces ateliers
j'ai quelques éléments de réponse en
plateau puisque vous êtes AC quelques
accessoires oui effectivement donc le
club nature effectivement se réunit une
fois par mois le mercredi de 14h à 17h à
la Maison de l'Environnement à Manil à
et ce que nous faisons en fait justement
pendant ces ateliers c'est on privilégie
d'abord la découverte en milieu de
proximité donc des mars des forêts à
côté de la Maison de l'Environnement la
découverte de la biodiversité de manière
générale les petites bêtes de la litière
de la forêt ou de la Mar et on aborde
aussi les thèmes du développement
durable en travaillant sur tout ce qui
est tri et recyclable alors pour le TR
recyclage on a quelques éléments qu'on
peut vous montrer ici comme la
confection de fleurs par exemple fleurs
à partir de bouteil plastique voilà
comme ceci VO un peu à l'antenne qui
effffectivement c'est pas des fleurs
très naturelles c'est plutôt du
plastique c'est g d'atelier met mettez
effectivement bien bien devant vous
comme ça on la on la verra mieux voilà
effectivement ça c'est une des
réalisations que vous réalisez est-ce
que ces jeunes sont réceptifs justement
à ce ce message de protection de
l'environnement oui oui effectivement
ils sont très oui très réceptifs ils
sont déjà plus ou moins sensibilisés par
leurs écoles et par leurs parents au
quotidien le rendez-vous existe depuis 4
ans et vous mettez en avant un label le
label club connaître et protéger la
nature CPN c'est quoi ce label euh alors
le club CPN c'est tout
simplement un un club labellisé par la
Fédération des CPN qui permet surtout
d'avoir accès à des ouvrages de qualité
des mallettes de qualité et la formation
des animateurs tout au long de l'année
alors quelques informations si vous
venez de nous rejoindre on parle de ce
club nature de l'association villeeverte
un mercredi par mois animations pour les
enfants à partir de 8 ans 8 9 ans de 14h
à 17h pour les détails pratiques et la
Maison de l'Environnement à manilamot il
faut mieux venir équiper aussi ça fait
partie des recommandations oui
effectivement casquette sac à dos parce
qu'on va sur le terrain on reste pas à
la maison deenvironnement ouais
chaussures bottes voilà tout ce qui peut
être amener voilà même boussole s'il
souhaite sac à dos voilà et ça un coup
une trentaine d'euros par an voilà
l'adhésion 30 30 € effectivement ensuite
on participe à tous les rang DESV il est
possible ou pas de venir en cours de
route pour les parents qui voudraient
inscrire leurs enfants par exemple sur
l'atelier de demain ou du mois prochain
sur le principe le mieux c'est de
commencer en septembre pour créer la
cohésionéqu voilà en fait les les aances
elles sont inscrites dans une
progression pédagogique du début jusqu'à
la fin de l'année donc en général ce
qu'on va en début d'année jusqu'à la fin
de l'année il y a une suite logique et
puis bon au niveau de la cohésion pour
les enfants c'est quand même mieux on
peut accueillir quelques enfants en
cours d'année mais voilà le mieux c'est
de nous rejoindre dès septembre à partir
du des forums des association ou nous
appeler directement à l'association pour
prendre des informations voir les
enfants qui puissent venir faire une
séance d'essai pour savoir sil
s'inscrivent l'année suivante là vous
vous adressez aux enfants qui sont
situés uniquement du côté de manilamo
non surtout le 5antinois voir plus loin
justement d'où viennent ces enfants
est-ce qu'ils viennent d'un peu plus
loin est-ce que l'ensemble des des
populations de différentes origines de
550 an eneline peuvent se rendre venir
vous voir ou quelle population vous
accueillez en fait la majorité c'est
Montini gu en cours magie VO par que l'
important pour le message c'est qu'il
soit véhiculé par un maximum d'enfants
j'imagine parce qu'il y a un message
derrière tout ça aussi c'est de respect
de l'environnement c'est fait partie
aussi du du but oui tout à fait mais le
but je crois que c'est
surtout de pouvoir permettre au aux
enfants de comprendre que en fait la
nature c'est quelque chose de simple
dîner et on peut vraiment s'amuser avec
on n'est pas à
l'école on intervient également dans les
écoles mais dans le cadre du club nature
voilà on n'est pas à l'école mais on
s'amuse en fait on apprend plein de
choses et comme vous les suivez tout au
long de l'année ceux qui sont arrivés en
septembre aujourd'hui ils sont un peu
plus libéré avec ça justement ils ont
moins l'impression d'être à l'école sur
la première séance ils sont comment
quand ils arrivent ah bah toute façon de
la première sens il sont mis dans le
bain cette année on av organisé un
atelier asses fédérateurs ils ont
décortiqué des des pelotes de réjection
doncà voilà c'est un atelier où la
cohésion d'équipe elle se faisait tout
de suite par
l'identification regarder ce que l'autre
avait trouvé il y a un vrai échange qui
se fait entre ces différents enfants qui
participe à ses ateliers l'association
villeeverte existe depuis 1988 pour
développer la réflexion de chacun sur
les enjeux environnementaux et sociaux
justement quels sont les autres actions
que vous pouvez mener là c'est l'action
l'une des actions principales ah non le
club nature c'est pas l'action
principale euh c'est une action qui se
fait en fait en partenariat avec la
maison de l'environnement de 50 ans en
iveline avec qui on est directement
partenaire on travaille également
beaucoup avec le PNR de la Haute Vallée
de Chevreuse dans le cadre d'accueil de
sesjours nature on travaille également
avec la Fondation Nature et Découverte
et c'est avec toutes les écoles de du
territoire de la casqui voilà pour citer
les partenaires principaux peut-être une
dernière question vous qui êtes
intervenante quels sont vos vos parcours
respectifs pour intervenir justement a
dans les écoles par exemple alors mon
parcours respectif donc c'est un BTS
Animation et Gestion touristique locale
une licence professionnel écotourisme et
ensuite de l'expérience lié à un service
civique en espace naturel protégé
sensibilité à l'environnement forcément
assez forte voilàoui voilà très très
forte par mes stages et mes expériences
voilà lors de petit lors de petit job
d'été et cetera voilà c'est important
que les intervenants justement et avec
les animateurs et cette fibre
environnement parce que pour la faire
passer aux enfants c'est plus simple
donc c'est un métier bah oui c'est un
métier passion dans le sens où on répète
beaucoup ou nous nous on connaît mais il
faut savoir réussir à le faire
redécouvrir à chaque séance donc c'est
sûr qu'il faut être passionn euh et
qu'on peut s'y prendre dès dès le début
des études à partir du bac voilà on peut
s'orienter très vite dans des filières
agricole qui qui permettent voilà de se
spécialiser pourquoi pas ensuite
participer aux animations mais du côté
des animateurs voilà rejoindre
l'association on donne en tout cas la
date du prochain club nature le 12
décembre demain 14h à 17h et puis le
site internet aussi de l'association
association villeeverte org merci toutes
les deux d'être venu nous parler donc de
de ces ateliers le rappel des titres à
présent les sujets abordés ce 11
décembre dans le 78 la colère et chefs
d'entreprise de PME contre la CFE la
cotisation foncière des entreprises ils
ont manifesté ce mardi après-midi devant
la communauté d'agglomération de CTIN en
iveline ils étaient également sur ce
plateau en début d'émission
l'association HF prévention intervient
dans la lutte contre le sida nous vous
avons proposé ce soir de découvrir le
travail de ses salariés et bénévoles sur
des lieux dit de sexe c'est le nom
qui est accordé à ces lieux en forêt de
plaisir par exemple où chaque jour entre
100 et 150 personnes y fréquentent
l'endroit une rue de la laïcité inauguré
à Guy encs après le rond-point des
droits de l'homme à la rue de la Liberté
la place de la fraternité tout cela
semblait bien logique et puis quand les
journalistes de TV fil 78 hostou Anthony
res notre journaliste sportif a testé
pour vous le taekwendo au sein du TKD 78
nous avons suivi ses premiers pas en
kimono et en ceinture blanche et ce
reportage sera à découvrir dans l'actu
le tout image de la rédaction à 30 et à
22h sur TVfil également sur notre site
internet je vous renvoie aux réseaux
sociaux pour commenter toutes nos
émissions et rendez-vous demain en
direct des 18h pour un nouveau 78 bonne
[Musique]
soirée